a new development is underway in the
northwest valley in centennial hills
which will go a long way towards
conserving water across las vegas mary
jane belliesa is live now with a look at
how this new reservoir will work this is
fascinating
mary jaden something that i think a lot
of people are unaware of tell us more
oh absolutely sherry and the goal of
this 600 million dollar project is all
to conserve water throughout our growing
valley and even though this reservoir is
located in centennial hills and fort
apache water from that reservoir will
reach communities all the way down here
in the west side valley and even as far
as henderson now that water is coming in
from the colorado river through lake
mead the las vegas valley water district
says we actually used 26 billion less
gallons of water than the all-time high
back in 2002 and that's with a much
higher population living here right now
water officials say these reservoirs are
just one of the ways we'll be able to
continue our accessibility to water and
water conservation throughout the county
it's a 5 million gallon reservoir
it will be one of
80 reservoirs that we currently have in
the valley
no matter where residents no matter
where businesses are
our job as an agency is to be able to
deliver water to those
to those homes to those businesses in a
reliable and efficient manner
with 90 of our water coming in from the
colorado river and lake mead the other
10 is coming in from groundwater wells
throughout the county and the expected
project completion date for the
reservoir out in centennial hills is
summer 2023 reporting live from valley
view in charleston mary jean vallieza
live local now